ANDREW WALES: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Behind the Code.
On today's episode, we're
going to be talking all
about using the data layer.
Actually today, we're going to
be talking a little bit more
abstractly about the data layer.
As most of you probably
know it, the data layer
is something you might use in
conjunction with Google Tag
Manager, for example.
So you might have some analytics
tags in Google Tag Manager.
And then you push information
into the data layer
from your page, and
that fires the tags.
And that's kind of
the common use case.
But we're actually
designing the data layer
to be a messaging bus that any
vendor, not just Google Tag
Manager, but other
vendors and services
might be able to
consume as well.
So we're going to talk about
what the data layer is,
and also how other services,
outside of Tag Manager,
can also consume the information
in the data layer using
a open source library that
we recently published.
And so to help us do
that, I've actually
got Brian Kuhn as a tech lead
on the tag Manager project.
And Lukas Bergstrom is our
Product Manager as well.
Brian, do you want to
give just a quick summary
of what you do on the team?
What's your role?
BRIAN KUHN: Yeah, sure.
So I lead the engineering
team in charge
of Google Tag Manager.
I was involved Google
Analytics for a long time,
writing they're
tracking code, and that
evolved into the product
we built for Tag Manager.
ANDREW WALES: And Lukas.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: The Product
Manager for Google Tag Manager.
And so originally, in ancient
times, a software engineer.
And then kind of lost the
plot and ended up as a PM.
But I work on collaborating with
Brian on the product road map,
being this kind of central
point of integration
for sales, marketing,
support, engineering,
to make sure that everybody
is talking to each other
and coordinated.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
So it's safe to say that
between the two of you,
you guys are kind of steering--
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Hopefully.
ANDREW WALES: And a day later.
BRIAN KUHN: We're trying.
ANDREW WALES: Try.
Cool.
Let's get into it.
I'll just quick show
the agenda roughly
of what we're going
to talk about.
We'll talk about overview of
the overview of the data layer.
Some of the design
principles behind it.
We'll talk about
using the data layer
to track State and Events.
Show some example
use cases when a data
layer might be
particularly useful.
And then we'll give you
some resources at the end.
So let's jump right into it.
Maybe we'll start with
the overview right
at the beginning.
And maybe Lukas,
I'll start with you.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Sure.
ANDREW WALES:
Basically, what problem
is the data layer solving?
What was wrong with the way
people were tracking before?
LUKAS BERGSTROM:
So when you talk
about tracking user
behavior on the web,
I think the first
thing that people
think about is
page view tracking.
At the base level,
you started out
by everyone put a
Google Analytics
tag on every page of
their site, and then they
could see which pages
got the most traffic,
and where people
were coming from.
We're a long way from that now.
We now are in a world
where people want to know,
who interacted with
this image carousel.
Who added something to their
shopping cart more than $500
in value?
So we want to know like really
detailed stuff about what
user behavior is.
And all of that requires
little bits of JavaScript
that ping servers with data.
And so where we
are today is, we've
got-- maybe the next
slide would be good here.
We've got dozens of
different services
that we use for things like web
analytics, conversion tracking,
remarketing.
And they all have their
own implementations of,
this is how you send me data.
And we've got on the next slide,
a bunch of different stuff
that we want to track.
And what that leads to
is, these M events N
services we need
to track them with.
So we've got, this is
matrix a different ad hoc
implementations that--
BRIAN KUHN: A mess.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: They get broken
every time your site changes.
So the idea of the data layer
is instead, on the next slide,
let's just abstract away that.
Just say like, all
right we're just
going to publish everything
that happens in the page,
that we know we're
interested in,
to just a common message bus.
And then all these different
services can subscribe to that.
So that's the
idea, I think Brian
can talk to what that gets you.
ANDREW WALES: So as a developer
then your concern is less,
how do I interact with all
these different tracking
libraries that I might be
working with on the same page.
And moves more to, how
do I just make sure
that I'm exposing with the
interesting things that
are happening on the page.
BRIAN KUHN: Exactly.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Exactly.
Exactly.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
Yes, so there's obviously
like a bunch of benefits,
we talked about a
few of them there.
It sounds like it makes things
a little bit less complicated.
But do you want to cover some
of these other ones as well?
Cause these actually
pretty interesting.
BRIAN KUHN: Yeah I can
probably talk some about this.
So when we're were
designing the data layer,
there were a couple constraints
that we wanted to deal with.
We didn't want to
slow down the page.
We didn't want to introduce
any additional global variables
other than just a
single data layer.
Because then in the mess that
he's talking about before,
you end up with global
variables for just
about every single
vendor that you're
talking about, and sometimes
multiple pieces of code
in that global name space.
So the data layer
really is confined
to that single variable,
that simple message bus.
The other thing that is
interesting about the mess,
is that every vendor has
their own different way
of capturing this data.
Some of them have
synchronous API's.
Some of them have boot
loaders that have to come in,
and pieces of JavaScript that
have to load before any of this
happens.
We wanted to avoid all that.
So if you go to
the next slide, I
can show you the
data layer really
is a basic JavaScript array.
It starts as a piece
of code that you
can put directly in the page.
There's no boot loader, there's
no piece of JavaScript that has
to load and provide API's.
No complicated things
for the page author
to actually put into the page.
Really we wanted to keep this as
simple as possible for the page
author.
So they really just have
to define this one array.
And then basically
append messages on to it.
ANDREW WALES: So it's an
array with some conventions
around how you use it.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Right.
BRIAN KUHN: Right.
ANDREW WALES: Now if
you we're using it
with Google Tag
Manager for example,
there is some code
for Tag Manager
that you would also need
to include, in addition.
BRIAN KUHN: Right.
So that's another goal of this
is really so your instrumenting
your site once and any
vendors that are on the page,
like Google Tag Manager,
or Google Analytics,
or other vendors out there,
they can consume that data.
So this puts a little bit
more work on the vendor side,
but it keeps the page author's
job very, very simple.
They basically just
create this array
of pushing messages onto it.
And then any vendors that have
to be installed on the page
can just consume that
data as it comes in.
The other nice thing
about this approach
is that it allows these vendors
to be loaded asynchronous.
So again, they don't slow
down the page either.
So if they come
along, they're not
going to actually
lose any of the data
that you're appending
onto the queue.
So you append message,
message, message.
And then they come along
somewhere along the line
and then they can actually
see the entire history
of what's been pushed.
And they can consume
it piece by piece.
So you can see in
this next slide,
this is an example of an initial
message on the data layer.
If your needs are simple
and you really just
have a static set
of key value pairs,
you can actually just do this.
You just basically have an
array with a single message
of the inside of it, and
then the key value pairs
that you want to use.
And then in the next slide,
we can show you how later on,
let's say you've got that
static set of key value pairs
in the page.
And let's say some
event happens.
You view part of the page,
or you click on a link,
or you view a carousel
like you said.
You can instrument those
actions in your page
to push additional
messages on to the queue.
And they'll get
processed in order,
by the various vendors they
want to read those messages.
And some vendors will
ignore messages and not
care about certain
messages, but other vendors
will care about your
carousel clicks.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: So we're
using the data layer
for two different
types of things.
And one is like, this
variable has this value.
Maybe just like a
static page level thing
you know when the page loads.
But we're also using it for
things are happening in time.
This event has happened, here
are some associated values.
BRIAN KUHN: Right.
ANDREW WALES: When
you say vendor,
just so everybody's
clear, would you
consider Tag Manager
itself one of those.
BRIAN KUHN: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
ANDREW WALES: So Tag
Manager's one vendor
but there could be some
other solution, that
also wants to use the
data layer which is fine.
BRIAN KUHN: Right.
We look at basically two
actors here, the page author
and vendors.
So we want to keep
it as simplest
possible for those page authors.
So this gets actually
into how vendors actually
consume the messages
that are being
pushed on to the data layer.
And now it's
probably a good time
to talk about something
Lukas was mentioning,
which is the abstract
data model underneath.
So for each message,
you're going
to pass in some key value pairs.
So over time, we keep
an internal memory
of that or a storage location
for all of those key value
pairs.
Basically keeping the most
recent value for any given key.
This kind of acts like
a database for all
those key value pairs, so
that you can come along
and it acts as a page view
level storage basically.
So if you're using a tool
like GTM or some other vendor,
you can use like a macro to read
those values at any given time.
You don't have to be there
at the time of the message.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
BRIAN KUHN: Because this is
baked into GTM at the moment,
we really wanted
to make the point
that, these vendors out
there other than GTM,
can also consume the data layer.
So we actually put out a
data layer helper library,
which is basically the piece of
GTM, that consumes the messages
and keeps track of the
abstract data model.
So this is actually out
on GitHub right now.
So vendors can actually
go and play with it,
incorporate into their
own products if they like.
And we can start collaborating
on kind of a industry standard.
ANDREW WALES: And you
mentioned industry standard,
was there some work you guys
were doing around the W3C?
LUKAS BERGSTROM: So we're
working with the W3C community
group to develop some kind
of common approach to this.
So this is the
architecture side.
So how you actually
encode, do this stuff.
Another part of
the W3C effort is,
what's the vocabulary you use?
What are the key
value pairs that
describe e-commerce events?
But we're working with
this and proposing
this as the standard
approach to how
you represent the data on page.
So a common message bus that the
other participants in W3C group
are mostly other tag
management systems.
So this would be hopefully
in a common message bus,
regardless of the Tag Management
solution you're using.
You can just push
data to that and know
that they'll be able to
consume it successfully.
ANDREW WALES: So
as a page author,
you don't have to worry about
dealing with different APIs.
BRIAN KUHN: Yeah so you
can use multiple vendors.
You can switch
vendors seamlessly.
It's very easy for you.
ANDREW WALES: And
I think Lukas, you
had some examples of
like real world use cases
where data layer would
really be helpful.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Yes who
are examples of developers
who would gain value from
working with this right.
One example is e-commerce
platform vendors.
If you want your users to be
able to track visitor behavior
if you're a site like
Yahoo stores or Shopify,
then you can either do dozens
of ad hoc integrations right.
Or you can basically
push data events
on to the data layer right.
For vendors to consume.
And in the near
term, when there are
vendors that still haven't
built in support for this,
you may have a
translation layer that
listen to the stuff
on the data layer
and then pushes it to the vendor
in the format they expect.
But at least there
you've abstracted away,
you don't have a direct
coupling between this vendor
and this button click
on a button with this ID
in class right.
All you all you need
to know is, what's
the interesting stuff
I want to track,
and then map those vendors
on to the data layer format.
So for e-commerce
platform vendors,
they get to basically just
instrument the site once
and then their users can
plug-in whatever performance
tracking vendors they want.
ANDREW WALES: On the
other hand, would it make
sense if you were pushing
things to the data layer
and you also using Google Tag
Manager, or one such vendor
and you can implement other
vendors via tags in Google site
manager, then that
would give you
a complete solution without
having to do the mapping.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Yeah exactly.
ANDREW WALES: But
otherwise if you
couldn't do that thought
GTM for whatever reason,
you're talking about kind
of having a second layer
translation thing to
look at the data layer
and then make it into the
format that the vendor needs.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Yeah
so like in the near term
is we're building
industry support,
you might need to build in
kind of just little translation
shims.
But it's still like a net win
because they're abstracted away
from the particular like
structure of like the website.
ANDREW WALES: And
then, I think there
was a-- we've talked about this.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: We've
been talking about this.
If your page author,
you just need
to think about the interesting
events and data once and then
plug-in vendors.
So I guess, looking two or
three years out, how do you see,
it sounds like you're seeing
the data layer as kind
of like a new standard
way for page authors
to pushing this information.
And hopefully we're going to
see other vendors, not just
Google Tag Manager but
a lot of other solutions
to be about to read
from that as well.
BRIAN KUHN: We'd
would like to see
this become the
mechanism in which data
is instrumented on a page.
And it really is like I
said, an event driven model,
so we're really
trying to be capture
all those pieces
of data, not just
like the constants in the page.
But all the data based on events
happening throughout the page.
Ajax apps, things like that.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: So as sites
get more and more dynamic,
this is like the perfect
architecture to support that.
And I think where
we'd like to see
this go-- one
example of the change
is have more and more content
management system self
instrument.
Just have them by default be
just pushing interesting stuff
on to the data layer, because
right now we live in a world
where, you've got content
management systems here, tag
management systems here, and
the CMS doesn't know anything
about the TMS, these
two parallel systems,
so when the CM'S
changes right, someone
changes the structure
of the site,
your tag management
setup might break.
But if the CMS is
self instrumenting,
you don't have that problem.
ANDREW WALES: That's cool.
And this also, you guys work
mainly with web apps, but does
this also apply to the
world of native apps,
because we do have a native.
BRIAN KUHN: Yeah we
use the same concept
on the native apps, the
available SDK as well.
ANDREW WALES: So it's the
same thing it's a dictionary.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Yeah.
BRIAN KUHN: Yeah because
there's no boot loading issues
there having to load scripts
and slow down the page,
they can actually have
a kind of more rich API.
But it's virtually the
same, same concepts.
ANDREW WALES: So just
get to some resources.
Make sure you guys have
links to some of the stuff
that we talked about.
We showed you the link
earlier but if you
want to check out the data layer
helper library, the open source
library that's on GitHub, we
have a link for you there.
And this would really
be for other vendors
out there, who might
want to also consume data
from the Date layer.
BRIAN KUHN: This is
open source so we
expect this to be collaborative.
If anybody wants to
contribute please let us know.
ANDREW WALES: And we did
talk about a little bit
about Tag Manager.
Tag Manager, obviously works
very well the data layer
and you can implement a lot of
other vendors tags through GTM,
so if you haven't
checked it out yet,
you can see Tag Manager
at Google.com/tagmanager.
Cool.
I think that's it
for today, if you
have any questions,
as always, feel
free to reach out to us on G
plus or reach out to me on G
plus as well.
Brian and Lukas, thank you
guys so much for joining us.
LUKAS BERGSTROM: Thanks, Andrew.
BRIAN KUHN: Thanks.
ANDREW WALES: And thank you guys
and we'll see you in next time.